Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs,
your one stop shop for all things graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website and APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straightforward and many of you who are listening have already used it
and created some amazing things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim.
Okay.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my God,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important,
it will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional planning.
For me.
It just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim.
Hello my frisky little kittens.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class performers to tease out through teens
the habits,
the influences such as favorite books and so on that have made them good at what
they do.
And the intention of course is to unearth the things that you can borrow that
you can replicate in your own life.
A [inaudible] and the guests range from chess prodigies to hedge fund managers
to celebs to fill in the blank.
And this time we have a fill in the blank,
which is a worldclass entrepreneur,
builder and investor.
His name is naval Ravikant.
Naval is the CEO Cofounder of Angel List.
He is a close friend,
has become an even closer friend because I am now an advisor to angel list.
He previously cofounded Epinions which went public as part of shopping.com and
vast.com also,
he has a very active angel investor and not surprisingly and has invested more
than 100 companies,
including more than a handful of Unicorn,
so called Unicorn Mega,
mega,
Mega I think on the sat.
Again,
mega successes,
his deals include Twitter,
Uber,
Yammer,
Postmates,
wish,
thumbtack and open DNS,
which Cisco just bought for 635 million in cash.
There are many more and you can find many examples on his angel list page,
which is just angel.co forward slash novel if you want to see mine.
It is a angel.co forward slash Tim and Angel List is one of the most incredible
tools for investing matching opportunities and investors that I've ever,
I've ever seen.
And it's very,
very disruptive to the venture capital space.
Uh,
there were I think around 10 people who were introduced to Uber Way back in the
day as investors.
And given the opportunity on angel list,
this was around 2010.
Uh,
I have led a couple of deals including ship,
s,
h y p.
You can check them out at [inaudible] dot com which is I think around 40 x up in
its valuation from the first time that I put it on Angel List and made it
available to people like yourselves,
uh,
who are accredited investors.
So you can check out all of my startup deals at angel.co/tim but let's talk
about Nepal and why he's on the podcast now falls on the podcast because he is a
very deep thinker who is very good at asking questions and testing.
In other words,
questioning the obvious and that practice and the practice of being hyper
rational and other people are emotional,
has allowed him to be very successful in the world of investing.
But it translates to many other sectors of life and business.
And that is why even if you have no interest in early stage investing,
I highly,
highly encourage you to listen to this.
Much like the Chris Saka episode,
uh,
Novalis had a huge impact on my own thinking about the world and startups and
investing.
But not only money,
my time,
my energy,
and he's been very much a mentor in that capacity in many others.
So I hope that my enthusiasm and enjoyment in this interview translates to the
same for you.
He is a treasure trove of many recommendations and a there you will probably
take down a lot of notes,
uh,
but you can find the links to the books and so on in the show notes.
And the show notes are@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash podcast,
all spelled out,
four hour work week.com forward slash podcast.
And without further ado,
please enjoy Deval Ravi con
neval welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me,
Tim.
I have really been looking forward to this because I always enjoy sitting down
in this somewhat artificial,
formal setting to talk with close friends.